[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
IAN LIVINGSTONE: Thank you.
I'm delighted to be
here and good to see
all you 10-year-olds playing
one of my game books.
It's brilliant to see.
Actually, it's quite interesting
talking about fighting fantasy,
because writing this
new book I was stuck
with a bit of a dilemma to write
for it for 10-year-olds, which
is the current market,
or 40-year-olds
masquerading as 10-year-olds.
Because I'm delighted
to say they've
survived the test of time.
So I'm here to talk about
the games industry--
why I think games is
such a wonderful medium.
Not just in terms
of entertainment,
but also in the potential
for fantastic learning
and education and how games
are transformational in all
our lives.
When we arrive in this world as
babies, we learn through play.
Play is natural.
We interact with
the world and just
make many discoveries by play.
And as we get older, we
enjoy solving puzzles.
We are naturally
curious and want
to solve these
puzzles, because that's
kind of the motivation of life.
And when we attach rules to
puzzles, they become games.
Now, as we said in
the introduction,
I joined the game
industry not long
after chess was
invented in 600 AD.
I wanted to turn my
hobby of playing games
into a career if possible.
And so two old school
friends, John Peake
in the middle, Steve
Jackson on the left, and I,
we met up back in London
in the early '70s.
And we all had pretty
miserable jobs, badly paid,
but we used to enjoy
playing board games.
And we thought, wouldn't
this be a fantastic job
to do to be able to turn
our hobby into our careers?
So we set about doing
that, and ultimately
we created Games Workshop,
known these days of course
for Warhammer.
But it didn't start off
straight away Warhammer.
There was a lot of struggles
before we got to that point.
We started off
publishing this highly
glossy full-color
magazine you see here
called "Owl and Weasel."
And we sent it out to
everybody we knew in games,
because we wanted to connect.
Clearly there was no other
way of doing it other
than to write.
Clearly there's no internet,
and there was no way
of putting out your message.
And one of the recipients
of "Owl and Weasel"
was this gentleman
called Gary Gygax.
Now, he lived in Lake
Geneva, Wisconsin.
And although we hadn't sent
the newsletter to him directly,
he got hold of a copy.
He wrote to us and sent
a copy of D&D to us.
This incredible game here.
Now, it didn't look
much, pretty plain box
with a very amateurish
drawing on the front.
But as soon as you opened
the lid and started playing,
it opened up the
world's imagination
like no game had
ever done previously,
and I don't think any
game ever will again.
Here was more of a designer
game kit than a game in itself.
It had no board.
It required one person
to be the Dungeon
Master to create a world
of monsters and magic,
labyrinths of passage ways,
populating those passageways
with rooms filled with
monsters and treasure.
And the other players to take on
the roles of heroes and wizards
and magic users and clerics.
And go on these fantastic
journeys of the mind, theater
on the fly, the
characters combining
as a dungeon party trying
to get through the dungeon,
the twisted dungeon of the
mind of the Dungeon Master.
So we became incredibly
obsessed with D&D. John, not so.
And within the next 12
months, he decided to leave,
because he wanted to carry on
making more traditional games,
and we wanted to do
these role-playing games.
So we thought this
was our calling,
and we started selling it mail
order through our third floor
apartment in Shepherd's Bush.
And we decided to be bold and
go over to the United States
to sign up all the
fledgling games companies.
And this photo on the
near side is Fritz Leiber,
science fiction author.
Next to him, Gary
Gygax, inventor
of D&D. And next to
him, Professor Barker,
who created a game called
Empire of the Petal Throne.
Next to him is me
holding the boxes.
Rob Kuntz at the
far end, another one
of the authors of D&D, and
Steve smirking at the front.
The worrying thing about
this particular slide
is the first three gentlemen
to my right are all dead,
and I'm next in line.
[LAUGHTER]
Bit of a worry but
hanging in there.
We also got to meet
Miss Wisconsin, 1976.
I don't know what she's doing,
but I'm enjoying myself today
at Google.
So we signed up all the
fledgling games companies
and ordered loads
of stuff, because we
were the big shot distributors
of Dungeons and Dragons.
And how weird we got
that distribution,
because we had no money.
And when we wrote to
Gary Gygax initially
we only had 50 pounds.
So we ordered six copies
of D&D. And on the back
of that incredible
order, Gary gave us
an exclusive,
three-year distribution
agreement for Europe.
[LAUGHTER]
Because he was also operating
out of a flat in Lake Geneva.
So kind of being a
role-playing businessman
about a role-playing
game was brilliant.
So he must have got
a bit of a shock
when he actually saw
this, but it was fine.
So he came back and
naturally, beforehand, we'd
been kicked out of our
flat by the landlord.
We were on the top floor flat.
And we didn't-- of course, no
mobile phones back in those
days.
Didn't even have a
phone in our flats.
There was only one public
phone on the ground
floor, which we shared
with our landlord, Paddy.
And inevitably the
phone would ring.
It would be a telephone sell for
D&D. We'd run down the stairs,
or if it was too late,
Paddy was there first.
Hello?
You want Games Workshop, do you?
Click.
He got quite irritated
by this, and he
used to tell us that
we really had to leave.
And there was people of course
milling around on the ground
floor outside, on the street
looking for this Games
Workshop, expecting
to find this shop.
Of course there wasn't one.
We used to have to
open the window.
You want Workshop?
Up here, mate.
Anyway this couldn't go on.
So we were given
our marching orders.
We had nowhere to live.
So we thought, we need
to get a bank loan.
Let's go and go see
the bank manager.
Hello, bank manager.
We've got this great game.
It's a role-playing game in
which you're a hero or wizard.
And you kill these monsters,
and it goes on for days.
And the box doesn't
look very much,
but it really is
an incredible game.
It's going to change
the whole world.
And the bank manager
looks at you,
a bit like a dog
watching television.
Has no comprehension whatsoever
of what you're talking about
and ushers you quickly outside.
So we had to make a
decision whether to have
somewhere to live or
somewhere to operate from.
Clearly we needed an office.
So we took on an office.
And luckily, Steve had
a van similar to this.
Not this one precisely,
but pretty much
like it, including the front
guard, and it was Van Morrison.
And we lived in there
for three months.
And people say these
days, wasn't it tough?
But when you're living in the
dream, it's not hard at all.
You're following your heart.
You're following a passion.
And yes, it was smelly
and cold and miserable,
but we were having
an incredible time.
We were in this smelly
old van from 1 o'clock
in the morning to
7:00 in the morning.
But we parked
outside a squash club
and joined the squash club for
a shave and a shower, et cetera.
And got really good
at squash by default.
And then into a little
mail order office,
where if a customer
came in, one of us
had to leave because
it wasn't big enough.
So that's it-- a progress.
But it was brilliant times.
And I always tell
everybody to, if they can,
to follow their heart and
start their own business
if they're able to or want to.
Inevitably, we had to
expand the business.
We'd had a lot of
trouble trying to get
other retailers to understand
what a role-playing game was.
They couldn't quite get their
head around not just a box
that wasn't a contained game.
But also you need peripheral
stuff, like miniatures
and magazines and supplements.
And it was just too much
of a malarkey for them.
So we decided to
open our own shops,
because we thought
that was the best
thing to have was a flagship.
And the one thing we wanted
to have with Workshop
was a Games Workshop experience.
So rather than hiring
traditional retailers,
we decided to hire
a hobbyist, those
who enjoy playing the
games as much as we did.
Because whilst they didn't
know about retailing as such,
they knew everything you needed
to know about role-playing
games and painting miniatures.
And so they created
this experience,
and they were effectively
incredible retailers
because of their enthusiasm.
So it became a
place to go and talk
about games and play games.
I think it still maintains
that spirit largely today.
We opened our first shop in
Hammersmith in West London,
and this was April 1978.
We were surprised to see
the length of the queue
on that glorious day.
I've been trying ever since,
well, in the last few years,
to reconnect with some of those
people that were in the queue
so we can try and do
an Abbey Road reunion
shot at some point.
I met three people so
far, and obviously you're
all far too young to
have been in that queue.
But if you know anybody
who was, let me know.
Might be a bit challenging
to do that photo by the way,
because it's now Bosnia and
Herzegovina Community Advice
Centre.
But I'm sure with a bit of
Photoshop we can do that.
Anyway, I'm no longer
associated with Workshop.
Steve and I sold out
in the early '90s.
But some of you
will know Workshop,
a publicly quoted company
now, doing wonderful things.
And I focus completely
on their own IP.
And I think that's
really important,
because intellectual
property is what
builds real value in companies.
It's often the case in
the UK in particular
that we have to trade away
our IP for project finance
so we end up being
a work for hire.
And if you want to build real
value into any company you're
starting up, make sure you
retain ownership of your IP,
because that's where the
value ultimately lies.
So we were big
role-playing fans.
We designed our own dungeons,
became fanatical players,
wrote some of the parts of the
rules and booklets for D&D.
And we also used to organize
these events called Games Day.
Workshop still does it
today, but ours was very much
focused on role-playing
and D&D rather than
Warhammer fancy battles
and Warhammer 40k.
And at Games Day 80,
Penguin Books took a stand.
And Geraldine Cook,
one of their editors,
was fascinated by some 3,000
or 4,000 people completely
consumed and obsessed by
playing role-playing games.
And she said to
Steve and I, would it
be possible for you
to think about writing
a book about the hobby
of role-playing games?
And we thought about that
for a second and thought,
wouldn't it be much more fun if
we gave people the opportunity
to experience what a
role-playing book is?
And if we could somehow
change the Dungeon
Master to be the book
and give multiple choice
and how is that idea?
And we called this
idea Magic Quest.
And she took it away as an idea,
told the MD of Penguin Books
about this
interactive book idea.
And apparently he
laughed so hard
he banged his head on the desk,
saying that wouldn't possibly
work.
No one's interested in
interactive entertainment,
certainly no one's interested
in interactive literature.
So it took us nearly
a year of convincing.
And Geraldine, to her
credit, was the person
who really drove this
through until they
decided they would test the
market through Puffin Books.
Because they observed
quite rightly
this is more likely to be
appealing to children aged
9, 10, 11, rather than adults.
So the very first
Fighting Fantasy game book
came out in 1982, "The
Warlock of Firetop Mountain."
And yeah, Penguin Books ended
up reprinting the first book
about 12 times in
the first six months
because they had no faith in it.
They couldn't really get
their head around themselves
what an interactive book was.
But they did, and the
reality of the day
was playground chat, the best
recommendation you could have,
and that was very successful.
And that message grew out
there, so we finally got
commissioned to write two more.
And here we are 35 years later.
And Scholastic, the
largest publisher of books,
children's books,
in the world are
taking on the mantle of
republishing, reimagining
Fighting Fantasy.
And some of you will
have in your hands
the new book written to
celebrate the 35th anniversary,
"The Port of Peril."
So even though you might
think it's too young for you,
maybe some 8, 9,
10-year-olds that you
know might appreciate it.
Hopefully you will
as well because I
write them for myself, not
necessarily for children.
So why are these
books different?
Well, they were taking the
essence of role playing
and giving people choice.
These were books in which
you, the reader, are the hero.
They're not a linear narrative
where you may or may not
connect to the main character.
These were an
interactive book in which
you make all the choices.
It was, in effect,
analogue hypertext.
At the end of each
paragraph, there's
400 paragraphs, which
if you read sequentially
make no sense whatsoever.
But at the end of the paragraph,
you're given a choice--
simplistically
turn left or right.
In this case, are you
going to talk to this guy
or get into the basket?
Are you going to
carry on walking?
So there's hundreds of ways
of going through these books--
but only one way.
And the difference
between these books
and other choose-your-own
adventures that
were coming around
at the same time
is that these were the very
first books with a game
system attached to them.
So it was a branching
narrative with a game system
to reflect the
combat and get people
to have a sense that they're
overcoming the monsters
that they meet along the way.
People subsequently
have called them
the gamefication of literature.
There's lots of terms about
Fighting Fantasy being
one of the great main
causes for interactive games
as we know them today,
particularly video games.
But back then, we
were just kind of
making it up as we went along.
We were delighted
by the success.
And art played a very
important part in the covers.
Because we were a Puffin
book, Penguin, the publishers,
were worried that because the
the books were interactive
with ghouls and demons and stuff
that that could be frightening.
So they wanted very tame covers.
They wanted covers that
had a little toadstool
and a gnome sitting on
them and butterflies.
And we wanted covers
that threatened to bite
the faces off the readers.
[LAUGHTER]
And we wanted to use our
Games Workshop artists.
And we won that argument,
I'm delighted to say.
And we used some of the
best artists around.
This particular guy, who
printed the blood beast
on Deathtrap
Dungeon, Iain McCaig,
he went on to create Darth
Maul for George Lucas.
So we were giving
young artists a chance
to be able to do what they
want to do for themselves
rather than being told
what to do by publishers.
And we also convinced
mainly foreign publishers
to use our covers as well for
the very same argument, that we
thought children get excited
rather than frightened
by the covers that we offered.
Sometimes some
territories thought
they knew better than
we did, and we bowed
to their greater knowledge.
So I'll show you the
cover that was used
in Japan of Deathtrap Dungeon.
[LAUGHTER]
I can't possibly
comment on that,
but it's safe to
make your own mind.
Anyway, the net result is
they got a whole generation
of children reading again.
Some 17, 18, 19 million
copies were sold.
This is theoretically
a great thing.
They were empowering, great for
reluctant readers, inspiring
children to write their own
stories, to become artists,
to enjoy the medium.
So it was also
found subsequently
that Fighting Fantasy game
books improved literacy by 17%.
And children were asking
their parents, hey, dad,
what's a sarcophagus?
And once there more and
write their own adventures.
It really encouraged
creative writing.
So you'd think you'd get some
good headlines in the media,
but no, I'm afraid not.
Not back in those days, because
there was no social media.
The children couldn't
get their message out
to tell their parents that
these were a good thing.
Being obsessed by these books
was seen as a bad thing.
The Evangelical Alliance
published an eight-page warning
guide about them, saying if you
read these books, interacting
with ghouls and
demons, you're bound
to be possessed by the devil.
There's no choice.
A worried housewife
in deeper suburbia
phoned in her local
radio station,
said that having read one of
my books her son levitated.
[LAUGHTER]
So the kids were thinking,
for one pound 50, I can fly?
Really?
Oh, yeah, we'll
have some of that.
And the local vicar
threatened to chain himself
to the railings of Penguin
Books until they were banned.
There were petitions
to have them burnt.
There were magazine articles,
this one in particular,
warning that children
actually participate
through their imaginations.
God forbid that
was ever to happen.
What a strange thing to
do when you can have nice,
safe stuff where you
don't have to think.
Petition sent in
to Penguin Books,
we the undersigned demand that
the series of Fighting Fantasy
game be withdrawn from
publication immediately
as we believe them to
be dangerous and harmful
to children.
I've got their addresses.
[LAUGHTER]
There will be a day
when I come back.
But the thing is, history
has never been kind to games.
Back in the 1850s,
"Scientific American"
wrote rather alarming
things even about chess,
that people should be doing much
nobler things with their mind
than wasting it on chess.
And of course when it
comes to video games,
the media goes into
an apoplectic frenzy
when talking about
some particular games.
Now "Grand Theft Auto V" is a
great British success story.
It generates a billion dollars
its first week of revenues
and should be celebrated as
bringing art and technology
together to create this
wonderful and interactive
entertainment medium.
And yet, the press largely
castigated it for its content.
And that's wrong
for many reasons.
A, "Grand Theft
Auto" is rated 18
and shouldn't be played by
children in the first place.
But it is an
incredible achievement.
The biggest entertainment
franchise in any medium,
is that not a good news
story for this country?
And there are many blockbusters
in video games that
are being developed in the
UK, for global publishers
everywhere.
We are a great nation
at making games.
And we have created some
great intellectual property
in this country.
These are some of the companies
I advise or chair or something.
They're all doing
amazing things,
generating original
content everywhere.
So if we can just pull
back a little bit and say,
how did this notion of games
being a bad thing come from?
Is it because play
is seen as trivial
and has no value whatsoever?
Should we stop at a certain age
to stop playing, playing games?
Why is that?
So I'm sure many of you are
familiar with this, games only
really became commercialized
with Atari's "Pong"
in the early '70s.
Yes, I got into video
games in the mid-80s first
designing the launch for a
small developer called Domark.
The game was called Eureka.
And Domark, three
of the companies
metamorphosed into Eidos
PLC in the mid-90s.
And of course, Eidos best known
for launching "Tomb Raiders."
And I was the executive
chairman when we did that.
So where did "Tomb
Raider" come from?
Again, lots of people think
it was developed in the States
or in Japan.
But it was actually
created in Derby,
right here and by this guy
in particular, Toby Gard.
He was an artist at Core Design.
Core Design was owned at
that time by CentreGold,
and we bought
CentreGold in March '96.
We being Eidos PLC.
And part of the due
diligence period
required me to go around
and look at all the studios
and the assets of CentreGold.
And when I went to Derby and saw
"Tomb Raider" in development,
I guess you could say it
was love at first sight.
It was amazing to see.
Not just an
interesting character,
but the fact it was great
technology, great graphics,
fantastic gameplay.
And the first games with a
3D character in a 3D world.
It had all the planets lined up.
But of course, everyone talks
about the main character,
Lara Croft.
And Toby, the artist, was
the person who created Lara.
Now, he'd been given
a task to replace
the lead character of a game
that Core originally produced,
called "Rick Dangerous."
And the reason was that
Rick had a slight similarity
to a character in a film
I've forgotten the name of.
But it was his task, as the
industry grew up and matured,
to obviously get
its act in gear.
So everyone thought
that Toby was
going to create
another male character.
But he'd seen the rise of girl
power and a cherry, Tank Girl.
And his original
sketch for Laura Croft
was in fact Lara Cruz, was
just a simplistic thing.
And another thing
I say to developers
when they're starting
off about the points
I made earlier about
intellectual properties,
if you can hang onto your IP, it
could be worth a lot of money.
What started as a simple sketch
turned into a multibillion
dollar franchise.
So let that be a warning.
So "Tomb Raider" came out
originally in October 1996.
And Lara Croft became a
pop culture phenomenon
not just in the games
industry but way beyond.
It became a main entertainment
franchise in the mass market.
And so the power
of the brand again.
When you own the IP,
you don't only just
get the revenues
from publishing,
you get all the
incremental revenues
from licensing and merchandising
and all these brands,
powerful in themselves.
So the value of
having Lara Croft,
it gave them incremental
revenue through promotion.
And of course, she didn't
go unnoticed by Hollywood.
Now, Hollywood traditionally
created their own IP, looked
to literature, to comics.
And now they're looking at
games because of the impact
that games is having on society.
And we managed to get ourselves
an executive producer role,
because we wanted to
make sure that Hollywood
didn't take Lara Croft
in a direction we
didn't want it to go.
So we had a veto over the
scripts and over the cast.
And when they suggested
that Angelina Jolie play
the role of Lara Croft, we said
that's absolutely fine with us,
no problem whatsoever.
[LAUGHTER]
Yes, those were the jolly '90s.
And so reunion with all
the Lara Croft models
with some old bloke, and
it was a very tough job,
and I survived it.
So console games, still
huge as we all know.
The console is not going away.
In fact, this
generation of hardware
has been larger
install base than
any other previous iterations.
So it's great that still
continues to grow the market.
But for some people, console
gaming is a challenge,
and the intimidation of
a 15-button controller
is just too much
for some people.
And then along came
smartphones, and of course Apple
in particular with
swipe technology.
And then anybody could
become a games player
by just swiping their
finger across the screen
and being able to access
an all you can eat store.
It was transformational
for expanding the market,
and this was additive rather
than replacing the existing
markets.
Of course, the challenge
today of course
is two million users
trying to reach
an audience of
two billion people
through the world's
smallest shop window.
But that's another story.
For every "Angry
Birds," there's probably
20,000 dead birds out there.
But that doesn't
stop people trying
to become the next big thing.
And I'm not going to go into
the challenges of mobile games
today other than to say
marketing, monetization,
metrics, and margin are
the most important things.
I don't have time to go
into the data of that.
But if I was
launching a new game
or advising people to make
a new game on the app store,
you've got to make sure you
have an open mouth on the icon
because that's really important.
Without an open mouth,
you're doomed to failure.
So we've seen games move from a
niche to a mainstream audience.
We see children still
loving playing games,
the young adults playing games.
You got old people like
me still playing games.
And we see games
pervasive everywhere
you go-- on public
transport, out in the open,
people are happy to
be seen playing games.
We're seeing games
become a spectator
sport, the huge rise of
e-sports and prizes to be won.
And people are very happy to
watch games being played live
or watching them being
streamed or watching people
playing games on YouTube.
It's an incredible experience
now and another great market.
The net result is the games
industry is a $100 billion
industry.
It's the largest
entertainment industry
in the world and again, a
great British success story.
But beyond entertainment,
I'd also argue in many ways
that games are
actually good for you.
A, they're social.
We're playing with our friends.
We're enjoying that
social activity.
Even for old people,
give rehabilitation
a sense of purpose, burning
off calories as well.
These are a good thing.
Games require to problem solve.
You cannot get through a game
without solving problems.
You cannot advance until
you solve problems.
And that is clearly
a good thing.
You're given
continuous assessment.
You're allowed to fail
in a safe environment.
No one is going to punish
you for making a mistake.
In fact, you're encouraged
to start again and try again.
It's not a binary decision--
you're wrong, you're
wrong, you're a failure,
and you're right.
You can try multiple ways.
That allows a conversational
thinking approach
to solving a game and doing
it in a very encouraging way.
Games can be used as a
contextual hub for learning.
Take a simulation game like
"Roller Coaster Tycoon."
You're building a theme park.
You understand the physics of
the rides that you're building.
You understand the economy when
you're pricing those rides.
You're understanding
staffing levels
as you decide how much
resource and overhead
you want to apply
to that theme park.
And if you do it right,
your virtual customers
will enter your theme park.
If you do it wrong, you
can tweak the parameters.
So you're encouraged
to try again.
And ultimately, over time,
everyone can be a winner.
It's not just you
on a random day
through an examination--
you're right
and you're wrong because you
remembered the wrong things.
So this is a great way and
a multidisciplinary way
of learning through games.
Games like "Sim City," you
can study all sorts of things
with "Sim City," even
urban regeneration.
You can imagine a geography
teacher goes into a class
and says, OK, kids, today we're
going to do urban regeneration.
You just see the color just
drain out of their faces.
And yet with "Sim
City," you can do that.
You can learn about it.
You can step into history and
understand the ramifications
of the decisions you make
by being part of history
in civilization.
You can understand physics.
You can understand ethical
problems in "The Walking Dead."
And then games like
"Minecraft" where
you're building these wonderful
3D architectural worlds
to incredible degrees and
share them with your friends.
I mean who wouldn't want
to become an architect
after playing "Minecraft?"
Games, going back to
the simulation thing,
for surgeons, for
the armed forces.
Clearly there's
no downside if you
get things wrong when you're
using simulation software.
And people seem still hung up
on games as being a bad thing.
These simulations are
games without the scoring.
And people still think that you
have to read, more knowledge,
and clam up this hard
drive with facts,
rather than teach
them how to think.
And so I usually
say to them, well,
when you next fly across
whatever ocean it is
and you think about your
pilot, how they learned to fly,
would you prefer that they
read by reading a book
or using simulation software?
Which is, again, to say a game.
So some of the
greatest people we
know in the world of technology
have really said, a lot of it's
down to games.
These four gentlemen all
say, the missing words
are playing and
games, and they all
attribute games to
being a wonderful thing.
And Demis Hassabis, as you
clearly know from DeepMind--
and I once beat him at a
board game, by the way.
I wish he was here.
I could sneer at him openly.
[LAUGHTER]
He's always said that
he's viewed his obsession
with playing games is training
his mind in multiple facets.
And he's a great living
example of the power of play.
So if you can part your
prejudice about one or two
titles and think
cognitively what's
happening when you're
playing a game,
all these things are
giving you life skills.
These are matter skills
for the 21st century
from just the problem solving
to the creative components,
et cetera.
There was a program on
Horizon about 18 months ago,
I don't know if
any of you saw it.
But they're trying to find out--
were games effectively
good or bad for you?
And at the end of the program,
they had some old people,
and they did an
MRI scan on them.
And said, go away with
this tablet full of games
and come back a month
later, which they did.
And they played lots of puzzle
games, little simple strategy
games.
And they did another MRI scan
and their cognitive activity
had really increased
substantially.
And it was really
put out there then,
maybe we should be giving
old people tablets to play on
rather than tablets to swallow
to solve their problems.
And the other great
things about games
is the industry itself
is a brilliant industry.
It supports so many great causes
and interacts and allows people
to do things that no
one ordinary can do.
Now Special Effects, of
which I act as an ambassador,
fantastic charity.
It gives children with
severe disabilities
the opportunity
to play and engage
with the world in which they
wouldn't have otherwise.
And they modify games technology
to bring an experience
for these children.
I'll just show
you a small video.
And if you have the chance to
help Special Effect, please do.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[LAUGHING]
[SHOUTING HAPPILY]
IAN LIVINGSTONE: That's the
great work of Special Effect.
And you never know, one day.
[LAUGHTER]
Maybe not in my lifetime,
but you never know.
So we play games.
We love consuming content.
But how do we
actually make them?
And how do we get more
diversity into games
from all society to reflect the
content, particularly women?
Well, we are a creative nation.
Look at our film, our fashion,
our music, our theater,
our publishing, and of
course our games industry.
And of course,
video games brings
art and technology like no
other medium, I would suggest.
The storytelling, the art,
and science and technology.
And as Google knows more than
any other company in the world,
I'll say, there's a dearth
of software engineers.
Not just for video
games industry,
but for all industries.
And I was involved
with campaigning
to get computer science on
the national curriculum.
As an employee myself
back in the day,
it was quite alarming
what a difficulty
it was to get coders and digital
artists and software engineers
of a high enough caliber
to work in our industries.
And it's not just about games.
It's designing a jet
propulsion engine
or fighting cybercrime
the way you guys do here.
It just wasn't happening.
So I went to Ed Vaizey, the
former culture minister.
And he pushed it straight
back onto us and said,
well, why don't
you write a review?
Which I did with Alex
Hope of Double Negative.
And the fantastic
research is from NESTA,
who funded all the work,
and [INAUDIBLE] studies,
and gave us two fantastic
researchers in Hasan
Bakhshi and Juan Mateos
Garcia, and of course
published the review.
And we were talking
about how we're
going to turn children
from being consumers
to creators, how
they're going to be
empowered for the digital age.
As Douglas Rushkoff said,
do we direct technology
or do we let ourselves
be directed by it?
Are we going to be in the
driving seat or the passenger's
seat of this technology?
So long story short, the
main problem we found
was that ICT as was
taught in schools
was not fit for purpose.
It was largely a strange
hybrid of office tutorials,
boring kids to death
with PowerPoint and Excel
and giving them
no insight on how
to create their own technology.
So our main recommendation
was to put computer science
on the curriculum as
an essential discipline
because this was nothing new.
Back in the 1980s, the
BBC was a cornerstone
of computing in schools.
And then at home,
everyone had a Speccy,
an affordable,
programmable machine.
And those two
machines themselves
were one of the instrumental
reasons why the video games
industry took off
so early in the UK.
And that all got
changed as people,
schools worried about people
accessing the open internet
and viruses and stuff.
So they were just allowed to use
other people's software rather
than writing their own.
Now, we did do a film.
We haven't got time
to show it today,
but you can see it
on YouTube or Next
Gen. It's about 14 minutes
long, which we submitted again
on our application.
Of course, we're also
thankful to Eric Schmidt, who
referenced our Next
Gen review in his Q&A
at this Mactaggart lecture.
And he was saying how
he was flabbergasted
that computer science
wasn't taught in schools.
And of course, if Eric
said it, it has to be true.
And the then prime minister
echoed his words saying,
we're not doing enough
for programmers.
And Mr. Popular,
one thing you have
to say in support
of Michael Gove
is that he was instrumental
in making the change.
He listened to not
just what I was saying
and Alex Hope was saying,
but the whole world,
including Google, the
learner societies,
every digital company
in the UK just about
was saying the same thing.
And he did allow the
computer curriculum
to take over from the
ICT curriculum, which
is a great thing.
So 2014, that happened.
Computing is here.
Who's going to be up
for the challenge?
Who's going to
teach the teachers?
I know this is some
of the initiative
that Google is doing.
It's great there are
resources everywhere,
as hope that creativity
is essential to this
because a lot of it is dry,
and I know a lot of children
are not enjoying it.
So we have to do a lot to make
computer science exciting,
show what can be done with this
wonderful thing called code.
I recently wrote a book called
"Hacking the Curriculum," which
is free in this month's
issue of Hello World,
if you happen to get one.
But this is trying to be a
practical guide and a fun
way for teachers to
teach computer science.
Because it can be argued
that computer science is
the new Latin
because it underpins
the digital world
in the way Latin
underpinned the analog world.
And I hated school.
And a lot of children
today hate it
even more through the narrowness
through which it's taught.
And as Einstein
said, the only thing
that interferes with
learning is education.
And Generation Z are different.
They are naturally connected.
Again, you know more
than anybody else
how they happily share
everything that they have.
They naturally collaborate.
When they go to school, that
is a different experience
altogether.
And with the furious
rates of change,
we have to train children--
well, train is the
wrong word, but allow
them to learn skills
that are going
to enable them to have
jobs, be ready for jobs
that don't yet exist.
And the World Economic
Forum recently
said that for 2020, the
three most important things
for any child is complex
problem solving, creativity,
and critical thinking.
Now, of course, it was OK
back in the day for everyone
to learn the same stuff,
because you're just going
to transplant these children.
They've all had their brains
stuffed with the same facts
into the factory,
because they were
going to do the same thing.
But we know the
robots are coming.
So there's no point in trying
to train children like robots,
because they won't
actually be able to compete
with the real thing.
So we have to teach our
children how to think.
Now, one of things I'm
also doing at the moment
is to set up a foundation.
We're going to be opening
to academies in 2019,
working in conjunction with
Aspirations Academy's Trust,
one in Bournemouth and
one in East London.
And trying to put some of the
things that we believe in,
some problem-based learning and
projects and all the contextual
learning to give real
meaning and understanding
for the children.
So acknowledge the importance
of but know how it's
equally important in my mind.
So let's get some more practical
work in the school room.
It seems to me that the
government is pushing it more
to academic success,
even arts exams.
Now you have to do a written
paper and theories and things.
And we seem to be stripping
creativity and diversity out
of the curriculum rather
than adding to it.
We're supposed to be a creative
nation that is doing so well,
our fastest growing sector.
So let's allow children to
enjoy what they read, especially
"Port of Peril."
[LAUGHTER]
Now, if you start children
off on Shakespeare,
chances are you're going to
put off reading for life.
You read Shakespeare
when you're ready for it.
So whether it's comics
or an interactive book,
the point is to get
children reading,
to enjoy the experience
and move on when
they're ready to
things that might
be seen as more challenging.
And let's not keep
teaching the same things.
We're not all academics
and yet require
children to memorize formula.
There's no reason we have
all these devices that can do
the solving of these formula.
I gave a talk to about 500
teachers about a year or so ago
and said, hands up,
anyone can do this?
And I think about
10 hands went up.
I'm sure all your hands
are going to go up.
But I'll try anyway.
How many?
Yeah, I knew that
was going to happen.
[LAUGHTER]
But I think you know
what I'm saying.
It's crazy if you have
devices that can do this.
We have to have the
context for children
in mathematics, how to
apply it rather than being
scared about it.
So let's use games
as a contextual hub.
This child here is
now understanding
by applying heat to
the surface in the game
of "Minecraft" to the
silica sand that he's found.
He can make glass.
And that will live with
him forever as he puts it
into the world he's created.
And Lego is doing quite a lot
too for creative education.
So let's get more of a hands-on
approach, get them to build
and make a game, do something
with robotics, anything
to get them making, not using,
and allow them to collaborate.
That's how we work
in the workplace.
It's not cheating.
It's what we do.
So why can't we have
that in schools?
And more introduction
of code clubs and accept
our differences.
I think this sums it
up really, together.
Are we saying the
elephant's a failure
because he can't climb a tree?
Now together we can
do wonderful things
because we are different.
That's the important thing.
If the problem is,
as Ken Robinson said,
this problem with
conformity is in education
that people aren't
standardized to begin with.
So there's no point in judging
everyone by the same metric.
So I don't know why
we're relentlessly
going along that route.
The Department for Education
cites China as best practice
for mathematics and want to
introduce Shanghai maths.
At the same time, China
is looking to the UK
to see how can
they move from made
in China to designed in China?
They want to move up the
value chain of creativity.
And so they want to know,
how do you become creative?
Well, we seem to
be doing everything
to strip creativity out of the
classroom, which to my mind
seems crazy.
So again, Einstein is
saying, imagination
is more important
than knowledge.
Knowledge is almost a given,
thanks to Google in particular.
So let's get children
to dream and understand
the value of the arts.
It should not be no
longer seen as either or.
The diverse opinions,
the self-expression,
self-determination
that the arts give
is not just good for
the creative industries,
it's good for all industries.
The greatest polymath of all
time, Leonardo da Vinci, not
just the world's best
painter but also an engineer
and a mathematician.
So let's embrace
the STEAM agenda.
Let's have arts front
and central to education.
It's not just about STEM.
Art should not be just seen
as a facilitator and nice
to have to increase
STEM performance.
And let's stop punishing
children for making mistakes.
Failure is just success
work-in-progress
as we saw in the game.
So allow them to fail,
not feel bad about it.
We all have something great
to do, we can all contribute.
So all I'd say to finish is
that in the analog world,
the winners were really often
down to the amount of capital
they had because you have
to build physical goods
and have expensive
distribution channels,
and that was quite complex.
But today, any child given the
right digital making skills
and entrepreneurial spirit
wanting to do these things,
allow them to build
goods and services
they can access global markets
through high speed broadband
and monetize the world.
So I think there are equal
digital opportunities that
were not available
in the analog world.
So hopefully they will
start their own business,
hopefully they'll hang
on to their own IP.
They might not become
the next Mark Zuckerberg,
but maybe they will become
a digital entrepreneur.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]